the Joe Rogan experience and also what
also what happened is that you know a
lot of these people is something that
people Americans kind of don't don't get
yet this isn't a Mexican problem anymore
specifically as far as the cartel
violence going on a lot of these people
had their kids up here in the u.s. in
the 90s a lot of these cartel guys you
know Chapo has kids had kids in the US
and a lot of these people are now coming
of age you know
so cartel influence in the u.s. is the
thing you're gonna start seeing if
you're already seeing it but you're
gonna see more of it because a lot of
these people are actually american-born
the US citizens now working in tandem
with any sort of interest down there so
that's gonna be the new shift you know
and you know people are sometimes kind
of horrified by some of the stuff that I
post up some of the cases down there
people can look up the Los Molinos gang
in in Southern California there were
actual cartel group that would kidnap
people in the US
dressed as federal agents in the US and
drag them back down to Mexico now this
happened a few book almost I think about
nine years back but this is happening
u.s. no it's not something foreign
anymore you know a lot of people want to
think that you can build a wall and keep
all that down don't get me wrong you
build that wall I have nothing against
it but selling it as a security thing
it's just I don't I don't think it makes
that much sense and a lot of in a lot of
parts where it's it is up violence is
rampant on both sides but if the the
argument would be that if the wall
didn't exist then it would be too easy
to come back and forth look at all spies
yeah it could could you know but again
drug tunnels catapults yeah drones are
drugs and like kidnapping people and a
lot of other things that you cut off at
least some of the vehicle or I guess
yeah I get it I get it and I think again
I'm not against the wall you know build
a wall that I interviewed a guy I do
articles for a few magazines
I interviewed a guy who was a Sakai out
quilty he moves people from the border
and he said this about the board's asked
them in the interview about the border
wall he said it's good for business you
know you make something seem like it's
harder when it is it and it's good for
business
well so you say listen I can't get to
over 3,000 gotta be five yeah it's
tighter yeah
or fly them to Canada and they walk down
which is that was his one of his one of
his new favorite methods yeah so
northern United States probably got a
lot of Mexicans now yeah
the candidate borders hilarious it's a
path yeah it's a carved out 100-yard Pat
we we put pictures of it up the other
day we like look how hilarious is the
difference you Mexico and Canada Canada
they make it easy to know where the
border is I just get across here a and
be fine snow Mexicans you know yeah it's
really strange well I mean it's the the
amount of creativity and problem-solving
that goes on on the criminal side you
know mm-hmm
the if if your best plan is a wall of a
secure wall these guys have been working
against that best plan for the past
twenty years so they are they're already
way ahead of the curve mmm you know in
that regard you know there was
interesting time in John and people can
look this up drone technology had I had
an upsurge in innovation in Tijuana out
of all places in the world for a time
you know mmm like why that's funny
what we're doing
[Applause]